drinnen im plenarsaal halten indem wir
jetzt auch gleich wieder zurückkehren
können die debatte aber weitergeben kann
plenumssitzung denn jetzt geht es um den
nächsten
bundeswehreinsatz und diesmal geht es um
die eu mission
und da geht es um ausbildung beratung
und training die wie gesagt wird jetzt
weiter diskutiert hier im plenum ein
echter blogger ist die erste rednerin
dazu
auf den weg zu bringen das war ja auch
der hintergrund der 2013 begonnen
europäischen ausbildungsmission für das
malische militär eine sicherheitssektor
reform muss aber immer mehr sein als nur
training von polizei oder militär gut
governance rechtsstaatlichkeit und
politische kontrolle gehören zwingend
dazu
jahrelang ist hier leider zu wenig
passiert stattdessen hat die korrupte
vorgängerregierung in mali das vertrauen
der menschen verspielt aus der immer
größer gewordenen unzufriedenheit ist
dann die militär runter über einen
putsch an die macht gekommen hat wahlen
abgesagt und denkt trotz zahlreicher
verhandlungen drohungen und sanktionen
nicht daran sich an den vereinbarten
übergangsphase zur demokratie zu halten
gleichzeitig arbeitet sie mit russischen
söldner und truppen zusammen die
sicherlich in erster linie
menschenrechte frieden und sicherheit
für die menschen in mali zum ziel haben
ende märz kam es in der kleinstadt nur
raten der südlichen region lockt ihn zu
einem massaker unter beteiligung
malischer und wahrscheinlich auch
russischer truppen die vereinten
nationen sprechen von 500 toten die
meisten zivilistinnen bis jetzt erhalten
un ermittlerinnen keinen zugang zu nun
war das ist völlig inakzeptabel die
vorfälle müssen schonungslos aufgeklärt
und verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft
die präsenz russischer sollten das
offensichtlich teil einer russischen
strategie den eigenen einfluss in afrika
auszuweiten so kann unsere
schlussfolgerung aber auch nicht sein
dass wir einfach abhauen wenn irgendwo
ein russischer sommer auftaucht aber
eine militär hinter die so eng mit
russischen truppen und söldner
kooperiert reformen verweigert und immer
wieder menschenrechte missachtet und
damit die grundlage unserer kooperation
der letzten jahre de facto komplett
infrage stellt die können werden und
dürfen wir nicht weiter unterstützen
und deshalb wird mit diesem mandat die
ausbildung beendet eine fortsetzung wäre
unverantwortbar gleichzeitig werden wir
den druck auf die malische militär unter
weiter hochhalten den vereinbarten
friedensprozess fortzusetzen setzen und
endlich fortschritte auf dem weg zur
demokratie zu machen auch zu diesem
zweck und um ein lagebild vor ort zu
erhalten bleiben ein paar wenige
soldatinnen in warmer der tat taucht im
mandat zum operationsgebiet nicht mehr
auf wie in den vergangenen jahren das
ist ein land in dem die
menschenrechtssituation furchtbar ist
und das von der demokratie noch deutlich
weiter entfernt ist als man
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ganz
anders zu bewerten ist unser engagement
in die scheer wir nicht nur die
ausbildung der spezialkräfte wie geplant
fortsetzen und in den nächsten monaten
abschließen werden sondern im anschluss
wollen wir weiter miteinander darüber
beraten welche bedarfe sie selbst sehen
und wie wir sie dabei unterstützen
können hier wird noch einmal deutlich
ausbildung ist eben nicht gleich
ausbildung so richtig es ist den tschad
auszuschließen und die ausbildung des
malischen militärs umgehend zu stoppen
so richtig ist es für eine echte und
effektive sicherheitssektor reform
weiter zu machen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gerade
die stimmen die auch in der
vergangenheit
berechtigterweise auf die schwächen der
mission einmal hingewiesen haben warnen
uns heute vor einem vollständigen abzug
fehler müssen wir jetzt endlich die
gelegenheit ergreifen und auch aus den
fehlern der vergangenheit lernen das
internationale engagement in mali das
land ist ja eines der ärmsten länder der
welt wie viele andere in der sache zone
auch leidet es besonders unter den
auswirkungen der klimakatastrophe er
lebt seit jahren eine ständige
sicherheitskrise das spielt die
zivilgesellschaft eine extrem wichtige
rolle gerade frauen und junge menschen
stehen dort mutig für wandel ein wir
müssen sie stärker unterstützen
und auch gerade auf die lokale ebene
schauen wo es perspektiven und
potenziale gibt die wird zu wenig hören
und wo es verhandlungsansätze gibt die
wir deutlich stärker unterstützen müssen
und auch aus diesen gründen haben wir
vorhin in der debatte darum geworben die
mission der vereinten nationen nicht nur
nicht zu beenden sondern sogar leicht zu
unter erhöhen und dass es auch hier in
den gesamtansatz ein sehr wichtiger
beitrag
mein großer dank gilt den soldaten der
bundeswehr und in vielen zivilen
experten die sich in mali unter sehr
schwierigen bedingungen für eine bessere
zukunft des landes einsetzen aber auch
ihm sind wir es schuldig dass wir die
mandate kritisch und schonungslos auf
den prüfstand stellen vielen geht ja in
der molly debatte der afghanistan
vergleich viel zu leicht über die lippen
aus meiner und ich denke immer auch über
das ende von mandaten sehr viel nach und
seit dem abzug in afghanistan noch mehr
wann ist ein einsatz endlich endgültig
gescheitert wann es ist besser
abzuziehen stadt zu bleiben und wie geht
denn ein verantwortungsvoller abzug und
welche folgen entstehen dann aus dem
vakuum das wir hinterlassen als
koalition müssen wir in mandaten auf
diese schwierigen fragen antworten geben
wir dürfen die dilemmata nicht
ignorieren klein oder schönreden wie das
in der vergangenheit immer wieder
passiert ist sondern wir müssen die
schwierigkeiten und spannungsfelder
benennen und beantworten eine werte
geleitete aktive aussenpolitik sie
wurden wurschtelt sich nicht irgendwie
durch wartet ab was andere machen und
dann heißt sie herzlich mit dabei zu
sein sondern sie gibt gemeinsam und
proaktiv mit unseren partnern voran und
trifft entscheidungen und kommuniziert
sie transparent deshalb passen wir unser
engagement der veränderte realität in
wasi an übernehmen auch weiter
verantwortungen der sachen region wir
überlassen russland nicht das feld aber
senden eine klare antwort auf die
präsenz russischer söldner wir beenden
in weiten teilen die zusammenarbeit mit
der militär unter aber verstärken unsere
unterstützung für die zivilgesellschaft
und die vereinten nationen für diesen
vorschlag werbe ich um ihre
unterstützung und daher die zustimmung
zum mandat vielen dank an jesus glauben
bürger mit ihren argumenten warum die
mission der europäischen union auch in
der nächsten zeit von bundeswehrsoldaten
begleitet werden so wir werfen ganz
schnell noch mal einen blick in die
sogenannte west lobby wo die abstimmung
zur un mission zu der die bundeswehr
beteiligt ist nach wie vor läuft noch
ziemlich viele abgeordnete die ihre
stimmkarten einwerfen während hier drin
im plenum diskutiert wird über die
eu-mission in der sahelzone und da
spricht jetzt annette widmann mauz aus
der unionsfraktion
es deshalb schwierig und sie ist komplex
und wir als union machen sie uns deshalb
auch nicht leicht nach dem erneuten
militärputsch im mai letzten jahres
seine schnelle rückkehr zur demokratie
und verfassung in mali nicht in sicht
ganz im gegenteil die malische regierung
verschleppten übergang durch wahlen zu
einer legitimierten regierung sie
arbeitet mit russland und den
sogenannten wagners sollten zusammen die
im verdacht stehen wir haben das gehört
für schwerste menschenrechtsverletzungen
in mora verantwortlich zu sein die
übergangs regierung blockiert deren
aufklärung sie behindert die arbeit der
internationalen missionen vor ort indem
sie zum beispiel westlichen
truppenstellern willkürlich flugrechte
zur aufklärung zur überwachung und
versorgung verweigert
schließlich erklärte das regime von
übergangspräsident kräuter erst vor
wenigen tagen den austritt marlies aus
der gruppe der g5-staaten und bezichtigt
jetzt den westen an einem mutmaßlichen
militärputsch beteiligt gewesen zu sein
maly geht seit geraumer zeit einen
eigenen weg das regime definiert seine
allianz neu und es geht immer mehr in
konfrontation zu frankreich und dem
westen während der gemeinsamen reise mit
der bundes außenministerin und ihrem
gespräch mit reuter wurde klar dass
molly sich in sachen sicherheit auf
russland stützt und auch dessen
völkerrechtswidriger angriff auf der
ukraine unter verbrecherische krieg
putins ist davon nicht abhalten
marlies enthaltung bei der abstimmung in
der un generalversammlung
unterstreicht einmal mehr diese haltung
es sind also berechtigte zweifel
angebracht ob es in mali noch eine
gemeinsame grundlage und ein geteiltes
verständnis für die zusammenarbeit mit
der eu und mit uns gibt und deshalb ist
es folgerichtig
als konsequenz unser militärisches
engagement für mali unter vorbehalt zu
stellen es heißt die tür wird nicht
endgültig zugeschlagen denn das würde
erstens nur russland in die hände
spielen dass unsere westlichen werte
dort diskreditiert und das vakuum
schwach und korrupt so staaten ausnutzt
um seine strategische einflusssphäre in
afrika zu vergrößern und zweitens würde
es dem system wettbewerb auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent weiter anheizen
und die spaltung in prowestliche und pro
russisch oder pro chinesische staaten
befördern meine sehr verehrten damen und
haben das kann eindeutig nicht in
unserem interesse sein
auf der anderen seite
bleibt mit dem vorbehalt aber auch eine
perspektive offen allerdings unter
klaren voraussetzungen
unsere bundeswehr kann und darf keine
sicherheitskräfte ausbilden die
gleichzeitig an schlimmsten
menschenrechtsverletzungen beteiligt
sind und genauso konsequent es ist daher
den schwerpunkt jetzt der militärischen
ausbildungsmission heute in mali bis auf
weiteres auf das nachbarland niger zu
verlagern liga hat sich nämlich als
verlässlicher partner für deutschland
erwiesen und wird als stabilitätsanker
für die ganze region gebraucht denn bei
unserem militärischen engagement im
sahel geht es zunächst um sicherheit es
geht vor allem auch darum die
grundvoraussetzung für staatlichkeit zu
schaffen und das vertrauen der menschen
in die staatliche ordnung zu starten
dafür steht der vernetzte ansatz der in
deutschland vor ort verfolgt und der
neben sicherheit auch stabilisierung und
entwicklung zum ziel hat das erwarten
die menschen zu recht seines die
beeindruckenden jungen unternehmerinnen
wie ein paar mark getroffen haben die
studierenden an der universität in ihrer
mail oder die menschen in grau und
quallen die sich ein leben ohne angst
vor gewalt und mit perspektive wünschen
für sie setzen sich unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten in - mal und in
mali unter sehr gefährlichen bedingungen
ein sie tragen mit ihrem wichtigen
dienst dazu bei failing states zu
verhindern und ursachen für flucht und
vertreibung zu bekämpfen dienen und ich
will dass ganz ausdrücklich sagen auch
den polizistinnen und polizisten in den
zivilen eugh ab missionen möchte ich für
diese schwierige aber vor allen dingen
für ihre hervorragende arbeit dann
mit der deutschen spezialkräfte
operation gazelle hat die bundeswehr im
rahmen von heute im einen maßgeblichen
anteil am aufbau und der ausbildung der
nigrischen spezialkräfte die neue
spezialkräfte schule in tillya ist
ausdruck dieser erfolgreichen
zusammenarbeit wir konnten vor ort
selbst erleben welch hohe wertschätzung
unser deutsches engagement dort genießt
und meine damen meine herren das hat
auch kündigen wenn die deutsche führungs
und sicherheitskultur bindet die kräfte
vor ort aktiv ein dabei hat die arbeit
mit gerade einem geschlossenen
nationalen verband enorm geholfen und
unser engagement bei ausbildung und
training agiert auf augenhöhe es
gemeinsam mit den partnern vor ort
konzipiert und england ihren bedarfen
ausgerichtet darauf können wir aufbauen
obwohl nigrischen sicherheitskräfte
enorm von der internationalen ausbildung
und ausrüstung unter stützung profitiert
haben sind sie der zunehmenden
terroristischen bedrohung alleine weder
quantitativ noch qualitativ gewachsen
gerade einmal acht sicherheitskräfte
kommen auf 1000 quadratkilometer land
die regierung hat es sich zum ziel
gesetzt diese zahl bis 2025 zu
verdoppeln ein minimaler aufwuchs für
niger aber eine enorm große
kraftanstrengung dabei sollten wir das
land nach besten kräften unterstützen
unser engagement in niger ist daher auch
nach beendigung der operation der zelle
eine gute investition in sicherheit und
in die zukunft des landes unter gesamten
sales region und aus diesem grund wird
die union der verlängerung und des
mandats und der reduzierung der soldaten
obergrenze für mali zu stellen
herzlichen dank und annette widmann mauz
aus der unionsfraktion und vielleicht
auch höchste zeit mal einen begriff ja
noch mal kurz aufzugreifen tm das werden
sie auch bei den nächsten rednern
gelegentlich immer noch hören müsste
eigentlich die utm heißen steht für
european junior training mission und
bezeichnet also die mission der
vereinten der europäischen union in der
sahelzone früher auf marli konzentriert
jetzt auf die sahelzone und den niger
viele kolleginnen und kollegen im
deutschen bundestag hatten ja die
gelegenheit mal in mali oder niger
gewesen zu sein und sich die lage an
geguckt zu haben vor ort wäre das wäre
das nicht konnte den dem empfehle ich
einen film den film timbuktu von
2014 preisgekrönt der noch einmal
deutlich macht welche hoffnungen die
menschen in der region haben welche
bedrückung welchen bedingungen sie
ausgesetzt sind wie dramatisch die lage
für viele menschen ist in mali aber
stellvertretend eben für die gesamte
region des sahel und das macht deutlich
wie dringend notwendig es ist dass wir
uns dort entsprechend engagieren und
viele halten dem entgegen das beispiel
afghanistan und sagen da hat es ja auch
nicht funktioniert und jetzt kannst du
ja auch nicht klappen ich finde so
können wir nicht denken sondern wir
haben in jedem einzelfall und
afghanistan werden wir aufarbeiten und
diskutieren die verantwortung darüber
nachzudenken was können wir tun aus
deutschland hinaus im gleichklang mit
den vereinten nationen um stabilisierend
zu wirken in schwierigen teilen dieser
welt wir hatten die situation das muss
man sich ja immer klar machen 2014 das
wir kurz davor standen das dschihadisten
am ende die macht komplett hätten
übernehmen können in mali das war der
moment wo frankreich mit kampftruppen
reingegangen ist wo - mark kreiert wurde
und wo am ende auch eben die
ausbildungsmission eu tm über die wir
jetzt hier reden entsprechend ins leben
gerufen wurde wir leben oder wir reden
über eine eine region von großer
instabilität mittlerweile drei der fünf
länder des sahel werden von einer
polizistin regierung geführt und
deswegen ist es eine schmale
gratwanderung
alles zu tun was wir tun können damit
die region nicht weiter im chaos
versinkt aber gleichzeitig wollen wir
natürlich auch keine pott putzt
regierung unterstützen das ist auch die
schmale gratwanderung die dieses mandat
beschreibt dieses eu tm mandat wo wir
auf der einen seite sagen ja wir wollen
da bleiben wir wollen weiter ausbilden
aber wir wollen eben nicht soldatinnen
soldaten einer putschregierung ausbilden
und deswegen eben die fokussierung und
die
konzentration auf nigeria und deswegen
auch die mandats reduzierung von 600 auf
in den letzten tagen bin ich da im
verteidigungsausschuss vorbeigelaufen
und da gibt es ja diesen gedenkort für
die soldatinnen und soldaten wenn man
sich mal
minuten zeit nimmt und mal guckt dann
sieht man eben wie viele soldatinnen und
soldaten aus deutschland am ende auch
gefallen sind in mali und deswegen ist
es notwendig dass wir heftig ringen und
dieses mandat und deswegen erwarte viel
habe ich das nicht verstanden und sie
wären es vielleicht selber gar nicht
wissen aber es ist eigentlich ein
bisschen unter ihren anspruch an der
stelle die verquickung dort vorzunehmen
und zu versuchen auch noch mal die
verteidigungsministerin an der stelle zu
kritisieren natürlich ist es unsere
verantwortung bei jedem mandat immer
darüber nachzudenken ist es
verantwortlich für die soldatinnen und
soldaten aus deutschland können wir das
risiko dem sie ausgesetzt sind
jedenfalls so einschränken dass wir
dieses mandat verantworten können
deswegen ist natürlich richtig dass die
verteidigungsministerin und wir alle
gemeinsam mit diesem haus darüber
nachdenken was sind die voraussetzungen
für solche militäreinsätze und wenn sie
nicht gegeben sind dann werden wir
diesen militäreinsatz auch beenden
müssen
aber wir halten ihn eben für notwendig
und deswegen müssen wir das erklären
müssen wir den soldatinnen soldaten
erklären dass wir glauben dass wir
unseren beitrag leisten müssen damit die
region eben nicht weiter im chaos
versinkt nicht nieder nicht die anderen
länder der saale wo eben islamistische
gruppen ihr unwesen treiben wo
kriminelle banden herrschen wo wir niger
als transitland haben für waffen drogen
und menschenschmuggel und eben auch an
rasantes bevölkerungswachstum
knappheit an ressourcen und
ernährungsunsicherheit und deswegen und
das würde ich dann auch nochmal für
unsere kleineren wie die kolleginnen und
kollegen der koalition auch ist es so
dass wir einen integrierten ansatz
fahren wollen dass wir verbinden wollen
das was entwicklungszusammenarbeit
ausmacht aber eben auch das was wir an
sicherheitspolitischen komponenten
entsprechen leisten können wir leisten
dort eine umfassende
entwicklungszusammenarbeit im gesamten
sahel wir unterstützen die justizreform
die unterstützten korruptions begrenzt
die unterstützten bemühungen zu den
zentralisierungen zur effektivierung der
polizei zur lokalen konfliktlösung zur
vergangenheitsbewältigung und zur
extremismus prävention um nur einige
beispiele zu nennen die palette könnte
man fortführen wir sind also tätig und
damit wir dort tätig sein können
stabilisierend wirken können im sinne
der entwicklungszusammenarbeit deswegen
ist es eben nötig auch eine militärische
komponente zu haben dazu gehört die
ausbildung jedenfalls der soldatinnen
und soldaten der regierung die dort
demokratisch gebildet werden das ist das
was wir mit diesem mandat eu tm tun und
ich will es noch mal unterstützen es
gehören zwei dinge mit dazu das eine ist
der selbstschutz und die fähigkeit zum
selbstschutz der deutschen soldatinnen
und soldaten und das zweite ist dass wir
alles tun und sicherstellen dass wir
keine putschregierung unterstützen
deswegen ist molly jetzt jedenfalls mit
kleinen ausnahmen nicht mit in diesem eu
tm mandat sollte sich das ändern weil
wir hoffentlich wieder eine
demokratische regierung auch in mali
bekommen dann würden wir im deutschen
bundestag zurück kommen und um eine
mandats veränderung werden vielen
herzlichen dank
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
komme ich zurück zu tagesordnungspunkt
26 die zeit für die abstimmung
ist fast vorbei ist
noch ein mitglied im haus das noch nicht
abgestimmt hat der kollege schwabe gut
der hat ja jetzt auch noch zeit wenn er
sich ein bisschen schneller bewegt
dann können wir die abstimmung gleich
schließen dann fahren wir jetzt erstmal
fort
in der tagesordnung und als nächster
redner für die afg fraktion spricht
gerold otte
[Applaus]
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen der letzten monate hat das
militär in mali und in anderen
westafrikanischen staaten fünf mal
geputscht kurz sagt ihnen hier vor einem
jahr das aktuelle mandat beschlossen
wurde risse mai
2021 das militär in mali die macht an
sich der transitionsprozess wurde
gestoppt und die waren auf unbestimmte
zeit verschoben das regime geht als
behindert - mal wo es nur geht und am
vergangenen sonntag mali auch noch
seinen auswahl aus der g5 zahlen
verkündet seit 2012 zum im inland ein
bewaffneter konflikt den bereits mehrere
tausend soldaten und zivilisten zum
opfer gefallen sind inzwischen sind mehr
monaten auch russische söldner der
sogenannten gruppe wagner aktiv diese
unterstützt das regime reuters im kampf
gegen seine feinde und islamisten dabei
gehen sie äußerst gewalttätig und brutal
vor es kommen bei deren aktion offenbar
immer wieder zu
menschenrechtsverletzungen
bericht der menschenrechtsorganisation
human rights watch sollten ende märz der
stadt nur manche streitkräfte gemeinsam
mit russischen söldnern circa 500
zivilisten getötet haben darunter auch
einige mutmaßten
das alles führte letztendlich dazu dass
die ausbildung malische einheiten durch
geothermie ausgesetzt wurde
halten wir also fest
das interesse ist einzig und allein die
eigenen machtsicherung russlands
interesse ist die schwächung des westens
beide verbindet das interesse an
zurückdrängen des einflusses frankreichs
und der eu in der region
was lässt sich daraus schlussfolgern
dass internationale krisenmanagement in
mali der aufwand stabilen demokratischen
rechtsstaat in systems gescheitert frau
stark zu machen scheiterten afghanistan
und ebenfalls in mali er wird immer
scheitern wenn interessen von helfern
und geholfen im nicht übereinstimmen
es scheint eben auch weil sie meine
damen und herren interessen mit
illusionen verwechseln beispielsweise
wenn sie versuchen mit stammte
skulpturen demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit zu etablieren sollte
sie unsere nationale interessen als teil
dieser illusion betrachten werden sie
ein ums andere an der realität scheitern
wenn die von interessen spreche denke
ich nicht an die schwammigen leitlinien
der bundesregierung und nichtssagende
frage die krisen verhindern konflikte
bewältigen frieden fördern oder ins
leere floskel wie die rede von einem
zivilen schub es geht um präzise
aufträgen unter dem richtigen ansatz von
mittel methode erreichbar sind
letztendlich sind sie ist meine damen
und herren die unsere soldaten in den
vergangenen jahren wiederholt in
auslandseinsätze geschickt haben bei
denen eingesetzte mittel und methoden
eben nicht geeignet waren ihren
illusionen auch nur ein stück näher zu
kommen
wot mali kommen wir noch die räumliche
eingrenzung zu mit einem einsatzgebiet
von mali mauretanien burkina faso und
niger an gebiet mehr als zehn mal so
groß wie die bundesrepublik deutschland
ist die trainingsmission zu einem sammle
mandat für unterschiedliche aufgaben
unseren soldaten geworden meinte
vielleicht noch sinnvoll zusammenspiel
aber keineswegs zielführend diese
feststellung fällt umso schwerer weil
dadurch die bewiesene
einsatzbereitschaft der mut und die
opferbereitschaft unserer soldaten
letztendlich vergeblich sind ich möchte
hier aber auch der persönliche einsatz
unserer soldaten der jugend mal
hervorheben weit entfernt von zu hause
in den familien in einem klimatisch
extremen umfeld und militärisch unsicher
region erfüllen sie dort mit großem
engagement den von ihnen und diesen
parlament überzeugen auftragen und dafür
haben sie unseren respekt verdient
[Applaus]
damen und herren es muss aber endlich
schluss sein mit auslandseinsätzen in
denen es letztendlich nur darum geht
irgendwie dabei zu sein und an der
vorgeblichen internationalen
verpflichtungen oder verantwortung
deutschlands gerecht zu werden das
vorliegende mandat lehnen wir deshalb ab
vielen dank für
[Applaus]
ich komme nochmals zurück
auf tagesordnungspunkt 26 gehe jetzt
davon aus der schwabe ist wieder
anwesend dass alle jetzt abgestimmt
haben
das ist der fall dann schließe ich die
abstimmung und bitte die schriftführer
und schriftführer dirk mit der
auszählung zu beginn das ergebnis werde
ich ihnen dann später bekanntgeben
nächste rednerin für die fdp hoffe da
haben wir doch glatt noch mit geriet das
frank bsirske in allerletzter sekunde
haus abstimmungskarte eingeworfen hat
und jetzt schauen wir zurück ins plenum
da ist marie agnes strack zimmermann am
pult vorsitzende im
verteidigungsausschuss
deutsche soldatin soldaten nach mali
entsandt und ziel war und ist es seitdem
ali und seine partner in der region im
kampf gegen den terrorismus zu
unterstützen
zum einen verstärken wir wie gerade
gesagt mit über 1200 soldatinnen
soldaten die stabilisierungsmission in
den vereinten nationen zum anderen haben
wir gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern malische und irische
streitkräfte ausgebildet in
internationalen einsätzen in denen die
bundeswehr beteiligt ist wird man öfter
süffisant hinter vorgehaltener hand na
ja die anderen kämpfen wir bilden aus
meine damen und herren das ist eine
aufgabenteilung die sinnvoll ist so
lange unsere ausbildung fruchtet und die
zur ausgebildeten soldaten befähigt
werden das gelernte anzuwenden uns auf
dauer auch weiter zu vermitteln train
the trainer
aber die erfahrung lehrt uns das
ausbildungs einsätze der bundeswehr so
gut wie immer mit einem besonderen
problem umgehen müssen wem bilden hier
eigentlich aus die entsprechenden
soldaten und soldatinnen als teil der
streitkräfte entsprechend in vielen
bereichen milde ausgedrückt nicht
unseren ansprüchen an eine armee
korruption fehlendes verständnis von
rechtsstaatlichkeit und menschenrechten
letztendlich gehen wir auch das risiko
ein dass die gelernten fähigkeiten nicht
in unserem freiheitlich demokratischen
sinne eingesetzt werden diese risiken
kennen wir und wir begegnen ihnen aktiv
indem wir gezielt die vermittlung von
grundwerten in die ausbildung mit
einbauen ja in mali gestaltet sich die
situation inzwischen schwierig und seit
dem putsch vor einem jahr erleben wir
zunehmend probleme auf regierungsebene
es wurde hier genannt die
militärregierung fall bei ihrer zweiten
erneuerbaren der transitionsprozess geht
nicht voran und es wird offen und ohne
hemmungen auch mit russland
zusammengearbeitet überfälle massaker
menschenrechtsverletzungen und das ist
natürlich ein großes problem und diesem
problem haben in der summe eine weitere
ausbildung der malische armee
schlichtweg unmöglich gemacht und ja es
ist ein bitteres zwischenfazit im
zehnten jahr die malische regierung ist
nicht so kooperationsfähig wie wir das
wollen und die sicherheitslage wird
schlechter terrorismus problem wird
größer und das ist unser dilemma das
ziel unseres einsatzes ist definitiv
noch nicht erreicht aber ein voreiliger
abzug würde diesen status zementieren
wir würden platz machen für islamischen
terroristen und meine damen und herren
das würde auch uns in deutschland in
europa unmittelbar betreffen und den
dritten platz machen für mehr russische
streitkräfte
die sofort das vakuum füllen würden ich
halte ist deswegen für richtig dass wir
vor ort bleiben zum schutz der
zivilbevölkerung mit - aber auch eben
mit eu tm ali im raum der salzstadt wir
können unseren einsatz aber nicht
bedingungslos um jeden preis fortsetzen
und die andere regierung hat sich
bekannt kein copy & paste mehr wie die
regierung zuvor wir evaluieren
diese einsätze und hinterfragen und wenn
die lage sich ändert dann müssen wir
auch das mandat ändern und ich danke
ihnen ausdrücklich frau ministerin dass
wir vor ort und sein eindruck machen
konnten und dass wir deswegen diese
ausbildung auf nie sehr beschränken um
die demokratischen kräfte der region
weiter zu unterstützen und ja wir halten
unsere tür auch für die malische
regierung geöffnet 1 muss aber klar sein
mali hat nur eine chance auf eine
einigermaßen sichere und stabilere
zukunft wieder mit den übrigen g5
staaten kooperieren wenn es auf die
forderung auch der ecowas eingeht und
auch die unterstützung der europäischen
union auf allen ebenen wieder erlangt
der fahrt aus dieser resolution
isolation ist deutlich die achtung und
wahrung der menschenrechte durch alle
staatliche akteure und es ist schon
ziemlich unerträglich wenn es zu einem
attentat kommt wieder frauen und kinder
ermordet werden und wir nicht die chance
haben diese vorfälle aufzuklären und
diese aufklärung von
menschenrechtsverletzungen meine damen
und herren erwarten wir und eine
beendigung der kooperation mit
russischen truppen das weiß auch der
malische
verteidigungsminister das konnten wir in
einem gespräch an dem die ministerin
beteiligt war auch kollege orte und ich
haben wir ihm sehr deutlich zu verstehen
gegeben meine damen und herren wir
werden das mandat wir werden den man da
zu stehen aber lassen sie nicht die
letzten sekunden den soldatinnen und
soldaten danken die in curicó über jahre
dort eine tolle arbeit geleistet haben
menschen ausgebildet haben auch familien
begleitet haben meine damen und herren
die an schweren attentat ausgesetzt
waren vor einigen jahren sie sind dort
geblieben um ihren auftrag zu erfüllen
den wir hier erteilen dieser auftrag ist
beendet der wird jetzt ausgesetzt und
unser dank geht diesen soldatinnen
soldaten von ganzen tag
marie agnes strack zimmermann
vorsitzender im verteidigungsausschuss
zur european junior training mission es
geht um beratung ausbildung und training
von sicherheitskräften in burkina faso
in mauretanien und niger und eben nicht
mehr wie bisher auch in mali nächste
rednerin kathrin vogler aus der
linksfraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit
abenteuerlichen argumenten begründet die
bundesregierung die fortsetzung des
bundeswehreinsatzes im sahel die
ehemalige europäische trainingsmission
eutm mali heißt jetzt fähigkeit aufbau
der europäischen union im sahel mit
schwerpunkt nieder warum weil nach
afghanistan nun auch in mali das konzept
der ertüchtigung krachend gescheitert
ist wovor die linke immer gewarnt hat
[Applaus]
verfolgte im sahel kontrakt von beginn
an eine postkoloniale agenda geprägt von
den französischen interessen am zugriff
auf die gold und uran vorkommen in mali
und niger und das sind die westlichen
werte über die wir hier reden während
die bundesregierung das heute
unerschütterlich behauptet der
militäreinsatz in mali sei ein
wesentlicher faktor für die
stabilisierung der sahel region stürzt
doch in der realität gerade ihren ganzes
propaganda bierdeckel gebäude mit großem
getöse frankreich sieht militäreinheiten
ab maly verlässt das militärbündnis g5
sahel und kooperiert jetzt mit
russischen söldnertruppen auch in
burkina faso ist inzwischen das militär
an der macht und der politische
militärische einfluss russlands wächst
auch dort in diese hat das militär jetzt
schon zweimal versucht die letzte
prowestliche regierung in der region weg
zu putschen und es kommen täglich zu
schweren menschenrechtsverletzungen an
denen das militär beteiligt ist und
sowohl sowohl im niger als auch in mali
zieht die bevölkerung in massen auf die
straßen und fordert den abzug der
fremden truppen so warum tun wir das
wenn es doch so sehr ihrer sicherheit
dient dass die bundeswehr in money oder
er ist die gründe dafür erklärt gegen
ein vertreter der zivilgesellschaft
militär ungefähr so die einsätze der
westlichen streitkräfte in mali hätten
die lage nicht zum besseren gewendet und
daher gebe es doch keinen grund
anzunehmen dass das jetzt in die sehr
anders sein würde hören sie noch mal den
leuten zu
dazu missbrauchen die eu staaten den
saal seit jahren für ihre zutiefst
menschenverachtende migrations abwehr
nie wer zum beispiel ist ein bedeutendes
transit land für reisende händler ebenso
wie für flüchtende und die militärische
grenz abschottung durch die eu hat viele
menschen wirtschaftlich schlicht
ruiniert in einem land das sowieso das
ernste der welt ist jeder zweite lebt
unterhalb der armutsgrenze und 17
millionen menschen hungern infolge des
klimawandels verschärfen dürreperioden
diese nahrungskrise und schüren
konflikte um wasser und land und von
karubis nach niamey muss es doch
inzwischen auf den verboten militär
befürwortern klar geworden sein dass die
ausbildung von soldaten gerade ein
solches krisengeschütteltes land eben
nicht nachhaltig stabilisiert und schon
garnicht
demokratisiert meine damen und herren
eine zivile nichtmilitärische
außenpolitik die mithilft menschen in
krisenregionen eine auskömmliche
lebensperspektive zu schaffen und ihre
konflikte friedlich zu lösen das wäre
eine chance für sicherheit und
stabilität dieser aufgabe stellt sich
die bundesregierung leider nicht und das
machen wir als linke nicht mit
kathrin vogler für die linksfraktion in
dieser debatte des deutschen bundestages
über die beteiligung der bundeswehr an
der eu-mission in der sahel-zone es geht
um die ausbildung und beratung von
sicherheitskräften über mali hinaus
zum antrag der bundesregierung
fortsetzung der beteiligungsergebnis zur
un mission
der multidimensionalen integrierten
stabilisierungsmission der vereinten
nationen in mali bekannt gegen
abgegebene stimmen
648 mit ja haben gestimmt
541 mit nein haben gestimmt 103 4
enthaltungen die beschlussempfehlung ist
damit angenommen ich komme zurück zu
tagesordnungspunkt 27 und der nächste
redner für die und das ist ein ziemlich
eindeutiges ergebnis aber wir hatten ja
im vorfeld würden auch unter anderem von
johann wadephul gehört dass auch die
unionsfraktion in dieser mission
zustimmen dort jetzt ist am pult thomas
ertl aus der unionsfraktion
vielleicht einsatz meiner forderung
vogler ohne sicherheit gibt es keine
entwicklung das ist ein grundsatz den
sie leider seit jahren hier nicht
verstehen denn die stabilität in der
region ist unser ureigenstes interesse
rückzugsräume für terrorgruppen
organisierte kriminalität und
menschenschmuggler darf es vor der
haustüre europas nicht geben ein chaos
dort
denn chaos mord bedroht nicht nur die
menschen im saal sondern am ende auch
unsere sicherheit in europa und deshalb
ist unser engagement in dieser region
nach wie vor richtig und wichtig und so
war natürlich auch der ansatz richtig
die malischen streitkräfte durch die
mission rtl ii zu stärken seit 2013 hat
die bundeswehr einen wertvollen beitrag
für stabilität und sicherheit in der
region geleistet und unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten haben ihren auftrag dort
professionell und hochmotiviert erfüllt
und dafür verdienen sie unseren dank und
unsere anerkennung
[Applaus]
doch wir können
wir können nicht so weitermachen wie
bisher denn es gibt entwicklungen wie
für uns einfach nicht akzeptabel sind
seit monaten fordert die internationale
gemeinschaft einen fahrplan zu
demokratischen wahlen vom
übergangspräsidenten güter leider ohne
erfolg da gibt es die offene kooperation
mit russland mit wagners eltern und die
weigerung massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen wetter dem
massaker im jura und der beteiligung der
un transparent aufzuklären die
bundesministerin habt bei unserem besuch
in mali diese dinge unmissverständlich
ein gespräch mit dem
übergangspräsidenten gut angesprochen
das war auch sehr sehr wichtig aber die
entwicklung ging leider negativ weiteren
den letzten tagen erfolgte dann auch der
ausstieg aus der g5 saal gruppe und
damit müssen wir feststellen dass sich
die rahmenbedingungen für das mandat
grundlegend geändert haben und deshalb
ist es nur konsequent dass
die beteiligung der bundeswehr an der
ausbildung der malischen
sicherheitskräfte nicht vorgesetzt
werden kann
trotzdem müssen wir einen weg finden wie
wir in der region präsent bleiben und es
ist daher ein richtiger schritt den
fokus von mali niger zu verlagern
liga hat sich trotz schwierigster
wirtschaftlicher bedingungen in den
letzten jahren zu einem stabilitätsanker
in der region entwickelt und die dortige
regierung ist ein verlässlicher partner
und an einer ernsthaften kooperation
interessiert
operation gazelle hat sich als erprobtes
konzept für die ausbildung der
nigrischen sicherheitskräfte erwiesen
und daher unterstütze ich ausdrücklich
dass die ausbildung dieser spezialkräfte
im rahmen des mandats fortgesetzt wird
und der eindruck vor ort zeigt auch dass
das wirklich in hoher professionalität
einerseits aber auch in einem geist der
partnerschaft
durchgeführt wird und an dieser stelle
eben auch noch mal herzlichen dank waren
die soldatinnen und soldaten die in
dieser mission dort im einsatz sind
die bundesregierung sollte sich aber
gedanken machen in welcher form das
engagement der bundeswehr niger über das
jahresende hinaus fortgesetzt werden
kann wenn die operation gazelle beendet
wird denn das internationale engagement
im saal und die stärkung der
handlungsfähigkeit der g5 staaten bleibt
weiterhin wichtig vor einigen wochen war
ich mit der bundesministerin in der
region und ich komme zum schluss für
präsidentin die eindrücke haben gezeigt
dass die region für enormen weiteren
herausforderungen steht
nahrungsversorgung
bevölkerungsentwicklung aber auch die
folgen des klimawandels sind dort
spürbar und deswegen ist unsere
unterstützung weiterhin notwendig das
ist unser ureigenstes interesse
sicherheit und stabilität weiter zu
fördern und deshalb es ist richtig wie
das mandat fortzusetzen und wir stimmen
die gerne zu erzielen waren
sagt thomas endl aus der unionsfraktion
mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss und
willkommen zu johannes alt aus der spd
fraktion
er ist mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe soldatinnen und soldaten
zweifel sind immer erlaubt wenn es um
die entsendung von soldaten
auslandseinsätze geht für mich ist heute
ein bisschen in emotionaler tag hier
heute in diesem hohen haus mit zu
beraten über einsetzen haben einsatzland
nämlich dreimal als soldat gedient habe
ich weiß wie es ist in bamako anzukommen
mit einem berg sagt mit einer
metallkiste und dort mehrere monate
verbringen und darum ist es sehr wichtig
dass wir ernsthaft diskutieren ob und
dieser folgenschweren entscheidung ob
ein investment ob ein engagement in
einem land gerechtfertigt sei nicht
dabei kommen viele aspekte zum tragen
sicherheitspolitischen erwägungen
außenpolitische ist unser engagement
vorausschauend umfassend und
multilateral ist der schutz der daten
gewährleisten aber auch ist der einsatz
effektiv oder nicht in mali engagieren
wir uns auf vielfältige weise nicht in
drei auslandseinsätzen wir haben gerade
über - mal abgestimmt es heute erneut
die - mandat wir sind bei euch hell
aktiv an der zivilpolizei mission und
wir engagieren uns eben auch bei rtl ii
und was ist der auftrag dieser mission
der auftrag ist was die befähigung zur
gewährleistung von sicherheit gestärkt
wird im sahel dass diese staaten ihre
territoriale integrität selber schützen
kann und das machen wir auf zwei weisen
seit 2013 mit der ausbildung malischer
streitkräfte logistische kräfte auch
infanteriekräfte führer ausbildung und
seit 2008 zehn mit der operation gazelle
also einer spezialkräfte ausbildung im
niger die einmal als kleiner einsatz von
kampfschwimmern in der wüste begannen
jetzt ein
nationaler spezialkräfte verband ist der
dort im einsatz ist wir müssen wir uns
aber wenn wir uns für einsätze
entscheiden auf fragen unterstützen wir
die richtigen womit nach stützen wir und
erreichen wir unsere ziele und da müssen
wir ganz klar sagen auch wenn nach einer
neuesten studie der
friedrich-ebert-stiftung
84 prozent der bevölkerung die
sicherheitslage in mali als besser
empfinden also im vorjahr auch in 90
prozent der malischen bevölkerung die
militärregierung oder stützen können wir
es unseren außenpolitischen zielen nicht
vereinbaren und unseren werten zu sagen
wir bilden weiter malischen soldaten aus
wenn diese menschenrechtsverletzungen
nach ihrer ausbildung gegeben
dennoch ist es wichtig einen
gesprächskanal nicht abreißen zu lassen
ist wie mit einem schmalen könnte
malischen generalstab bleiben werden wir
unseren schwerpunkt auf niger verlagern
und dort 230 soldaten einsetzen um
weiter spezialkräfte auszubilden denn
diese regierungszeit stabilitätsanker in
der region will trotz ihrer schwierigen
rahmenbedingungen dort einen beitrag
leisten für stabilität im saal als
demokratische regierung
womit erreichen wir unsere ziele und
zwar dann unterscheidet sich der einsatz
in niger und die spezialkräfte
ausbildung doch von dem engagement mali
bisher dann haben wir in mali nur
ausgebildet aber kein material zur
verfügung gestellt was oft dazu geführt
hat dass soldaten nach ihrer ausbildung
nicht in ihrer funktion eingesetzt
werden kommt auch nicht dem
ausbildungsverband weiter haben wir das
in liga verändert wir stellen
infrastruktur wir stellen die ausbildung
und wir stellen die ausrüstungen der
tüchtigen die nigrischen
sicherheitskräfte und leisten damit
einen nachhaltigen beitrag zu einer
stabilisierung einer region
[Applaus]
wir sollten immer schauen kein mandat
ist alternativlos das gebietet der
respekt die verantwortung die wir
unseren soldaten die wir in die welt
schicken und gegenüber deren familien
denn letztendlich ist es so dass immer
das risiko besteht dass soldaten an leib
oder seele verwundet zurückkehren oder
sogar gefallen in einem metall sagt
zurückkehren
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir dieses
mal da ihr hobby ihren das haben wir uns
aber koalition vorgenommen und ich hoffe
es unsere nationale sicherheitsstrategie
dazu beitragen wird es hier noch
einfacher an festen kriterien evaluieren
können lohnt sich engagement lohnt es
sich nicht wie erreichen wir das und das
haben wir getan wir haben den
personaleinsatz reduziert die haben den
schwerpunkt verändert die haben
gestrichen aus dem mandatsgebiet und ich
denke alle dass wir dazu beitragen dass
wir jetzt mit diesem ansatz erfolgreich
in niger weiter agieren können und auch
in einem jahr wenn dieses mal dazu über
prüfung ansteht erneut darüber sprechen
können ob wir unsere ziele erreicht
haben oder nicht und dementsprechend
gegebenenfalls noch einmal anpassen
werden
halte mal die letzten sekunden an
erlauben sie noch aus der fraktion die
linke eine zwischenbemerkung dazwischen
fragen ein
die soldaten können sich auf uns
verlassen dass wir verantwortungsvolle
entscheidungen treffen ich möchte noch
mal einen soldaten danken die sich in
mali engagieren die die schwierigsten
bedingungen ihren dienst leisten mali
und im sehr und
möchte für die zustimmung zum mandat
werben vielen dank
[Applaus]